yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game playing white against XX got
quantum complicated name let's see what
opening we we get Kings Indian agung
fault he's asking me you on IM yeah one
until the name okay so let's let's see
the Kings onion let's play the the same
ish
yeah here white has more than one idea
can play 92 Bishop g5 or Bishop e3 I
don't let see what turn line he's coming
up with also check the profile on his
only playing 15 minutes basically 1315
minute games this is a lot it came yeah
here black has some and wide choice of
this Lee this amateur sir quite quite
old line and we can play a 5 the
classical reply that was I kasparov's
favorite interestingly enough it never
had the super great reputation always
believed to be slightly passive but he
played this um 9205 hmm i think 92 first
added term it's both possible you can
also play d5 immediately
yeah here black can has two main options
taking on default or playing on a slow
move like c6 night d 7 if you take on
deform we get a position that its
simular to to the classical okay 1960
96's I'm usually a bad idea in this in
the set up against the samish because
white quickly set up this g-form
formation got 93 coming and this
prevents f5 gap prevents a 5-4 makes it
difficult to play at least if black
really wants really tries hard he can he
can play a 5 i'm not sure you really
want to i want to do that him is writing
to me i hate playing against the Samish
llaman thus understandable if you are if
you play on a second red line like this
and so it's a good line but it's not
that why should have i clear at the edge
or something okay I fire this is
probably the right of the best way to
play how to how to do this now
if I take if I take on f5 twice but the
end is got this fish in the screen edge
for checking the Sun irritating I can
play away if I have many ideas here
actually could you I could also take on
f-5e fgf night h5 it's not bad at all I
can take and play a GF GF Bishop g5 how
many many interesting ways to play
I'm not sure at all really fit even this
is a interesting gfgf EF night f5f5f5
Bishop d3 queen edge for checkup God
Bishop f2 so it cannot really give the
check so we must retreat and it's wide
open this position on the King really
hard to believe
sure what is need to take ok now this
Queen edge for I have Bishop f2 so he
needs to need to move the roof first
okay Queen edge for a store still the
move to to check it would be nice if I
just managed to to guess along Queenie
to and castles but he's got this check
Bishop f2 Queen f4 maybe
and yeah it doesn't look great for black
or anything I'm thinking about night
before so it's not better before I
threaten 95 and maybe maybe this is a
good good idea yeah I like the smooth on
Queen edge for Bishop f2 Queen h3 that's
also 9485 Queen edge for Bishop f2 Queen
f4 hmm check for something else even
should have to clean a form
yeah I overlook this
hmm Hey look g1 tween f3 as the Sun some
ID am with this
yeah what you want Queen takes Queen to
group takes I can obtain IG higher
because these three hangs ok I have 96
at the end but its forebear not great
yeah let's not spend much more time I
don't want to protect it with a passive
movement cannot be right and here i can
always take kicking me too and do what
my g5 should be here at least some
compensation yeah but it was a battery
played by me we really shouldn't get
this far
now maybe taking on that high first so
often wasn't one the best this is
curious it doesn't take why wouldn't you
take an idea okay takes on e4 now Bishop
takes should all be always safe of
course I'm speculating a bit i'm not
sure if he maybe even can we can maybe
even take a h2
Wow yeah it's really uncomfortable what
am i doing now
cannot casa loma should be three Queen
edge for and I don't have no really no
good one don't don't really see a movie
am I good a good move takes rook takes
looks completely completely stupid
no i don't i don't really see a move
cannot turn spend the whole day now i
can just play Queen edge for I don't
don't have a good reply to that I was
thinking maybe just back on f2 and
speculate that he won't take on h2 what
does is not exactly a great way to flame
you can also just play clear for
repeating of course not you place for
win
it's not not like I'm having a great
idea cm hmm I can't even cancel on here
amazing I need to get my stuff in playa
even if I sacrifice yet another poem
with Queen fo take f3 bishop age 6 is
just playing rook f7
yeah maybe I'm threatening bishop age
six now
I can't thank you Queenie for whatever
it's just two pawns in King a jade yeah
this is so simple simple and good try to
download the tree farm yeah Queenie form
it could be an idea I can play the three
yet it looks a bit bit weakening on the
long diagonal bottom I'm much past the
stage where I need to worry about
weaknesses the only way to to do
something in this this came as a somehow
made them whether put some silly tricks
chaos is not really helping him now I've
got work reform
Quincy to maybe so this is some pressure
by now now unfortunately i'll look Lee
eight can we should / h 6 is never an
idea that push of age successor is a
move not now of course but I need to
prepare this it's not not so easy home
to play this I have evil protected in
case you want to jettison apart and
cause the H porn if you cannot really
move want to secure the king and then
try to probe a bit more the King Fahd he
cannot really move so so much here
you should we go out because route g8 is
made the queen is tied to to the defense
of the bishop and I can tell play h5 and
fos well maybe before but this can after
rookie forward from the pressure d4 also
terribly backfire maybe he should have
tried for for b5 my desk in a two and
then maybe something like Queen on the H
file a TRO gauge for Kelly smacking a
sir not safe exactly but safer than
before all right how to do the snow
should I am plain go into h three Andrew
Paige home
then play Queen f3 inside and the show I
can take route 37 now this is probably
good enough for draw after queen of
three Queen after your text d5 so I
probably need to exchange group textbook
g7 Lupe's reroute a seven then I'm
threatening group g 7 okay place it in
something Fred there's something else
and while the way I'd like to try and
win so probably no no alternative I'll
wait wait wait here and I'm not sold on
the idea that i need to take care
unnecessarily maybe i can can play
something else if i play and probably is
not working we should be two or
something i can take on v6 but it
doesn't really help k me I wonder if
maybe Luke this have a stronger you two
taking this yeah this is stronger in
fact I can really try to get to looks on
the seventh and I get the deep hole
let's take it you are like this now the
sir shouldn't be worse anymore
that's probably no way to win here yeah
I get to look some centers also always
the young escape hatch so the same they
can take on on age six hunter toggle
through page six route d6 book page six
I probably he must do that i do not see
anything else no it's taking quite some
time here not sure what is what is
thinking about Luke 86 Suzuki it made so
he should really take this I don't see a
pawn moves what what what point you
should help you maybe you can place to
play III with Lucas happiness it's a
draw
yeah curious it's really risking to lose
on time here you know maybe he had hoped
for more but after this cell this
transformation into the rook endgame the
bubble who can get it was very clear
that white shouldn't lose I think yeah
what what's like is going on here it's
got a fantastic connection is not
disconnected knowing what what okay
yeah what can I do have no winning on
time here haruka seven on problem black
resigns yeah i'm not sure what he did
them just maybe a I don't know doorbell
ringing or something yeah this is
probably if just a draw you can take
this and yeah Here I am I don't think he
can they cannot keep the part I mean if
he tries this this is probably risking
risking too much but he can easily have
abandoned one of the points look
somewhere to activate the King I mean
something like this and then then use
the king and draw is a deep I mean draw
is a behind a flag scope the one with
with the outside passer so it's it's
it's more like me drawing but I can play
a 4 B 4 a 5 and 10 12 volt others yeah
the opening was curious try simply
didn't simply didn't didn't refute this
and this is refutable too no doubt about
that absolutely nowhere where Martha or
anyone would would play this maybe this
was this was one of the things that I
considered maybe this was better i don't
know i did it looks some quite
uncomfortable for black it seems that
what I did wasn't great
maybe a try this this really is not not
great yeah Queen takes I thought that
this should should be some compensation
now look here is 95 and through here I
can maybe just strengthen the position
of it I mean this looks like i have some
compensation they are all the computers
actually I'm saying why it is so much
better with Bishop e3 I didn't saw that
I only thought that there should be
something but I didn't didn't really see
the concrete move okay played dad Queen
d2 no was good now didn't see that yeah
after this I'm I'm just I'm just worse
idea of course just grab this and I
don't eat whatever I don't have anything
i just now lost those two pawns really
bad this now is something i can't even
take with the Queen it's not the
ridiculous but ok this is the easiest to
this narrow gauge for the threat our
computers completely cold blooded once
played before now that this is
yeah maybe you guys had no special I
don't know yeah not the greatest game
ever he played this really well
considering the the rating also but at
the anti-air just a strange time glitch
yeah thanks for watching